CBS News chief Washington correspondent
major Garrett and chief legal
correspondent Jen Crawford are with us
from Washington Jen let's begin with you
let us for a moment pretend there are no
political ramifications today and take
it as a strictly legal hearing from a
legal perspective what are you looking
for what are the key questions from both
sides of the aisle well I mean as we saw
at Nancy's report the Democrats are
going to try to focus on those possible
instances of obstruction and the point
of that is to try to get Muller to say
or at least indicate that he thinks
president Trump could have been charged
with a crime if he weren't the president
now remember there is that long-standing
Justice Department policy that says
sitting presidents can't be charged with
crime so Muller didn't even analyze
whether or not that he thought that
Trump could have been charged with
obstruction of justice now that's where
Attorney General Bill bar comes in when
I interviewed him in late May he told me
he was surprised and thought Muller
could have reached that conclusion so he
picked up the ball he and his team in
the Justice Department looked at the
evidence looked at the facts and
concluded the president had not
committed that crime of obstruction of
justice you're going to see the
Democrats really press Muller on that
whether he you know he thought that the
Attorney General was right that the
Attorney General made the right call
whether or not the Attorney General's
four page summary of his report was
misleading to Congress in to the
American public I think you're gonna see
potentially some tension there between
Muller and the Attorney General or at
least the Democrats are going to try to
expose that he's so major let me go to
you president Trump said yesterday there
was no obstruction a topic that
Democrats will likely grill Muller on
this is something that the president has
said over and over and over again and
yet there's a Pew poll out that shows
that 50% of Republicans think that mr.
Muller has been fair by most accounts
well sure
and whether Robert Muller has been fair
or not is less important than the
underlying evidence and when you talk to
the president's lawyers and there have
been a lot of them some on the team now
some used to be on the team but they all
come up with the same general conclusion
which is lots of things the president
said and did some in public some in
private when you read them in the malla
report sound obstructive but legally are
not
and they don't really sound like the
actions of a president that we
historically have been comfortable with
in turn a in our nation that's a
separate question that we're not going
to put aside the politics of it what do
you do about conduct in the Oval Office
that sounds obstructive but legally
can't be prosecuted or in this case
won't be prosecuted that's a question
for the deliberative body that's holding
this hearing the United States House of
Representatives what are you going to do
with this body of evidence there's a
sense that robert muller can help them
make that determination but robert
muller when he did his a very brief
statement before the public a month ago
said there's a constitutional means by
which all of us can be handled when he
was telling Congress is if you want to
convene impeachment hearings that's your
decision don't expect me to make it for
you and don't expect me to tell you what
to do about it I have a question for you
both because most people in this country
have not even read the Muller report yet
58% of the people who were polled say
they're actually sick of it they don't
want to hear anything more about it so
what do you guys think can be
accomplished today realistically with
these congressional hearings well the
Democrats have a theory gale which is no
one read the book maybe they'll watch
the movie which is today is this the
movie well my sense of it is if it's a
movie robert muller is not going to be a
matinee idol he is going to be someone
who is going to refer to the report
dryly repetitively yes no and not try to
dramatize the underlying body of
evidence he's made it clear this is the
evidence we found it's your decision
what to do about it and that's a
political call as much as a legal one
yeah I mean he's done this a lot he's an
experienced former prosecutor had the
FBI
he's coming up there it's a reluctant
witness he said he's not going to go out
of the you know kind of boundaries of
that report so we're expecting fireworks
but we may not get a lot all right we
will all be watching major I love the
movie analogy thank you very much good
to see you guys we'll see a little bit
later on in just over an hour we will
bring you Robert and Muller's testimony
in a CBS News special report
CBS Evening News anchor and managing
editor Norah O'Donnell will lead our
coverage on that it starts at 8:15
Eastern 7:15 Central right here on CBS